watch dogs too is hiding more than a few  Easter eggs I'm Tony and this is your  confidential gamespot news update one  particular mission and watchdogs to  tasks you with stealing a sci-fi video  game trailer from Ubisoft's in game  office and a report from kotaku says  it's for a totally real game the space  exploration title which may be called  pioneer was once planned to be announced  in 2017 but the game is being quote  retooled with several developers  replaced in recent months this is  certainly a unique way to reveal an  upcoming game if it's true in other  watchdogs to news the game seamless  multiplayer won't be available until  later due to technical issues in the  meantime you can check out GameSpot's  review and progress for more and for all  the latest Ubisoft news you're already  in the right place